[Applause]
both questions about dialogue and
engaging in dialogue with people so the
first issue that I face is I have a very
high need for intellectual stimulation
and I can't get that with most people
it's something like you can you can have
a dialogue for a time but then titrate
openness yeah and then out then they
sort of run out of ideas they can keep
up and it sort of falls apart okay this
is the problem that intellectuals have
are quite frequently is that they sort
of once they start reading difficult and
rewarding stuff yeah they stopped
wanting to talk to regular people and I
think that contributes to the disconnect
that you see between intellectuals and
working-class people and stuff like that
and the other question I had was about
okay wait I don't know if that's the
question I mean I believe there's a
question in there but I question is how
do we dress that how should I address it
and is that something that can be
dressed well part of part of the answer
to that is that's what the universities
were for I mean you know not everybody
is equipped to or interested in engaging
in high-level discussion of abstract and
creative ideas you know you hear this
idea that everyone's creative that's a
lie it's as straightforward as that drew
creativity is very very rare and so and
if you happen to be a creative person or
if you happen to be someone who's
profoundly interested in ideas you are
in a pronounced minority just as you are
if you happen to be extremely
extroverted or extremely agreeable or
extremely conscientious these are
minority issues and what you do is you
find like-minded people who are capable
of engaging that we know a heavy weight
with heavy weight weight lifters compete
with heavy weight weight lifters for a
reason and everyone thinks that's fine
the same thing applies to intellectual
and creative endeavors so what you do is
you try to find a community where that's
that's the nature of the community and
you likely have to find a relationship
like that as well you know so I don't
think so I think what contributes to the
siloing is the arrogance that goes along
with it because if you're you
you can be interested in ideas and you
can be creative well that's the
arrogance of the intellect right that's
the thing the Catholic Church had warned
about for centuries is the arrogance of
the intellect so because if you're if
you're wise as well as smart and there
is no relationship between being smart
and being wise they are not the same
thing
there's no quick pathway from smart to
wise and many of the people who I've
known who were very wise were when some
of them were intellectually impaired and
were still wise you know so it's the
arrogance that brings up the block and I
see this for example happening in the
United States in particular because the
last time I went down there for example
I was I had friends down there and and
some of those friends are very very
smart people and some of them were
talking about the Trump voters and they
were talking about the Trump voters with
contempt and I thought you better watch
that because that's 50% of the damn
population and it might be convenient to
think that they're stupid and beneath
you but it's not conducive to a civil
state and there's no evidence that it's
true because there isn't a straight line
between intelligent and wise and so I
think that if you're if your character
is developed and you're intelligent
you can have your siloed creative
community but you develop enough wisdom
so that you can see all the things that
people can do that are of high ethical
utility that are outside the
intellectual domain you know and I think
that's why in the New Testament I think
that's why Christ is a carpenter right
because well first of all carpenter is
one of those jobs that when you're
dishonest it manifests itself
immediately because what you build falls
down and so if you're an honest
carpenter you build a good house so that
there's a nice metaphor there but it's
also it's also a warning in some sense
against the the equation of intellectual
brilliance with moral superiority and so
if the intellects would drop their moral
superiority and that chance there is of
that then that divide between the
working class say and the elite would
would resolve and there's every
reason to have respect for decent
working-class people I mean it's on
their labor as the left-wingers at least
hypothetically agree that the entire
edifice of the culture is is resting so
you can have your cake and eat it too
but you have to not assume that your
niche makes you superior and it's very
difficult for smart people especially
smart there's a scene in Nietzsche's
it seems thus spake Zarathustra where 0
through Stroh the Prophet comes down
from the mountain and he comes into a
public square and there's this crowd
around this little midget who's only
about this high who has a gigantic ear
and everyone is marveling at him well
that's what the modern intellect is like
it's a midget with a giant well mouse
generally not an ear and the the the
being is underdeveloped but the
intellect is hyper activated and and it
makes the person extraordinarily
unbalanced and as part of Kaz they they
can't compete outside the intellectual
realm and that makes them very bitter
because they tend to think well god I'm
so smart everything should just come to
me it's like sorry that's not how the
world works and and it also that that
and that
that that attitude is immediately
evident to people that they're talking
to when they talk in the manner that
they talk if they are arrogant
intellectuals of that sort you see that
in the Simpsons did a good job of that
with comic book guy right I mean he was
completely useless in every possible
dimension with an IQ of about 160 and
it's very annoying to people who have an
IQ of 160 that they can also be
completely useless but it happens a lot
so yeah
you